when looking at Donna transfers today so
this is like downloading stuff uploading
stuff and it's just something different
but it's a connected to storage okay so
I want you to complete this sentence for
me of the average download speed 4g is
now i'm gonna give you an australian
number in a second now before you think
of a number maybe you like I didn't even
have a 90-year of what this number could
be and I wouldn't blame me because you
don't have to know what this is but
maybe you experienced it when you like
know you're waiting what is this no bar
in Australia okay now I've deliberately
sort of made this bit difficult for you
cuz I provided no units right like how
do you even measure a speed or you'll
see generally these days is a number
like this back in my day there was a
instead of em but you know technology
okay
now doesn't stand for but it stands for
bits
do you remember what a bit it's one
eighth of a pion okay it's just a zero
or a one okay which by the way tells you
why boots are called bits it's not just
cuz bit is a word for like a small piece
of something it actually said it's an
acronym that acronym it's an
abbreviation of binary binary digits
okay are you dodging it's a bit now
don't write this number down I'll tell
you what this number was last yeah and
then I'm going to ask you I'm never
going to last you I make a prediction
for what it is this year
okay now I'm just going to quote the
Australian number Telstra this is what
the 20 well this is whatever the last
year's recorded um average speed was for
users across the 4G network that's what
it was
SIA now keeping your mind via the
unstoppable march of technology forward
what do you think the number is either
that's a super disappoint you because
the answer is that there's all of the
towers and that kind of thing and all of
the wires and cables that can make is
they look bigger and then there's all
the rest of us every time we put it on
rice on the network and we all we all
get on anybody's got like you know a
decent that removal with their family
and everyone's like you know maybe
they're in business and everything is
suddenly like what happened to my video
okay why don't slow down well the reason
why is the same reason why there's no
message
people and it hasn't been upgraded
yesterday so right with me what this
means is mega bits per second now this
is even more different than you already
think it is not only is it bits not
bytes right so if I were to converts
into bytes and have to divide by eight
but even more confusingly remember
yesterday I made a big deal about how
when you go through mils two leaders to
Killa Leo's to mega litres right it's
part of a metric system so we multiply
by a thousand do you remember that and
then I said when you're storing things
when you go from bytes to kilobytes to
megabytes
you're actually not in thousands you're
in a thousand twenty fours right okay
get this when you're talking about
tighter transfers you've got data
storage that's like I've got a high
drive this is I'm downloading something
or completing something this actually
goes back to thousands now
if you feel like oh man that's confusing
why well there's a it's out of have to
give to you but only few hours so for
now I'm going to gloss over it you can
come back you can ask me at the end but
you don't need to know why to do the
questions first so let's work with this
okay
so let's actually go with this and let's
try and see how close Nick was because
this is not a bad absolutely I don't
think 13 bits per second that's an
average speed
so if I write 13 mega keep your mind
that for data transfers this is back to
well if its maker it's gonna be time to
am blowing it all right this is 1 0 0 0
2 0 0 so this is 13 million bits per
second ok that's what this average speed
okay so I want to try to translate it a
little bit to get to Peaks units right
so first thing we're gonna do you can I
hope you wrote this down off the phone
and - a yesterday I've gotta get four
bits two bytes so I'm gonna divide by
eight so you can go ahead and divide
that by eight and that's going to give
me a bunch per second can someone tell
me what the number one six two five how
many 0s dream okay cool so we've
convened two bytes that's great now to
go from bytes to kilobytes okay remember
remember you've now transition to a
different kind of unit right how many
bytes are there in a kilo but dollars in
the 24 right thousand and 24
I bet Speedway it's like I changed from
thousands to 1024 is my made way through
either that's confusing so if you want
and explain all that up but for now this
is why every step of the way
I mentioned this song last week rather
than like just doing all my numbers and
then adding units at the end I'm going
to say units every single time just so
I'm really clear what I'm convinced so
I'm gonna divide 5024 and that should
get me to cubans one five eight six all
make it point million okay now just just
for the sake of it since this is quite a
large number we've successfully
transitioned into on the units that you
suggested before but i can go on more so
into someone's divided by 1024 one more
time and give us a ship being
approximately equals one point all right
so megabytes per second right now that's
average download speeds over 4G as they
quoted okay doesn't know any questions
on that
yes actually that's a great question I'm
gonna put in the translation every
single time okay so I've done watching
one two three four steps of conversion
okay so I'm actually gonna leave with
every single one so you know first away
from kikyo
okay from megabits per second two bits
per second okay so I multiplied by a
million why women okay I'll come back to
the points a thousand tons a dozen okay
why is it no 2024 I'll explain
yes yes you do now if you remember I
didn't bring them again but you can look
it up fairly easily if you look back
again the formula datasheet right it
tells you how to get from bits to bites
bites tequila bites etc it doesn't tell
you about this stuff about okay so this
is something which is worth knowing you
need to be able to interpret